liebe bundesregierung jedes klima
kabinett am freitag habt ihr das hier
raus gebracht und viele fragen sich
jetzt nur eins nämlich etf nein herr
söder so werden wir unsere klimaziele
nicht erfüllen und die welt für unsere
kinder nicht erhalten ich will kurz
erklären warum nicht über vieles haben
wir ja schon gesprochen zur erreichung
unserer klimaziele brauchen wir einen
co2 preis lasst uns über die höhe dieses
co2 preise sprechen denn hier die
momentan der wichtigste knackpunkt aus
dieser expertise von mercator institut
für klimaforschung und dem potsdam
institut für klimafolgenforschung wird
eines deutlich wenn wir unsere
klimaziele erreichen wollen dann ist ein
co2 preis alleine zwar noch nicht die
lösung aber ein co2 preis muss die
hauptrolle spielen in dem maßnahmenpaket
er muss die haupt maßnahme sein der alle
anderen notwendigen zusatzmaßnahmen
untergeordnet sind hier besteht ein
wissenschaftlicher konsens eine
hauptrolle kann ein co2 preis aber nur
spielen wenn der preis stimmt der preis
darf nicht zu niedrig sein wenn man im
geldbeutel nicht spürt dann gibt es auch
keine verhaltens veränderung also nicht
vom einzelnen und auch nicht von der
industrie oder von den banken
wenn man aber was spürt dann führt ein
co2 preis zu einem sammle effekt weil
wir jetzt einen universellen anreiz für
alle haben der die vermeidung von co2
ausstoß attraktiven hat dieser universal
anreiz ist das was wir unter
lenkungswirkung verstehen und genau wie
sein lenkungswirkung wird der co2 preis
als hauptinstrument empfohlen das ganze
ist sozial gerecht möglich mit
entlastung von niedrigverdienern aber
dazu kommen wir gleich wie hoch sollte
der co2 preis also sein damit er diese
wichtige rolle übernehmen kann das haben
die experten berechnet meinem fixpreise
steuer sollte der preis für eine tonne
co2 im jahr 2020 bei 50 euro anfangen
und bis 2030 auf 130 euro ansteigen
zumindest wenn wir unsere klimaziele
erreichen wollen was die regierung will
so sagt sie soweit sind wir immerhin
schon statt steuer oder festpreis kann
man auch auf das konzept emissionshandel
setzen da gibt es ein festes co2 budget
also eine maximal menge an co2
ausgestoßen werden
die höhe des co2 preises wird beim
emissionshandel prinzipiell durch die
höhe des co2 budget es bestimmt also
durch die co2 menge die maximale aus
geschossen werden darf denn die genauen
preis ergeben sich dann durch angebot
und nachfrage
und je weniger ausstoß rechte vorhanden
sind desto höher wird der preis jetzt
gibt es da aber folgendes problem sagen
wie es gibt neue technische
klimafreundliche innovationen die dafür
sorgen dass weniger co2 ausgestoßen wird
super das wollen wir aber dadurch sinkt
der co2 preis das heißt co2 ausstoß wird
an anderer stelle wieder attraktiver und
das führt dann wieder zu mehr emissionen
deshalb empfehlen experten einen
mindestpreis für die tonne co2 der nicht
unterschritten werden darf auch ein
höchstpreis pro tonne co2 der nicht
überschritten werden darf kann sinnvoll
sein auch wenn es auf den ersten blick
kontraproduktiv klingt aber eine klima-
und energiewende muss längerfristig
planbar sein ich muss heute schon
investieren um in 15 20 jahren gut
dazustehen ein kreis korridor also ein
mindest und höchstpreis sorgt für
planungssicherheit und erleichtert damit
klimafreundliche investitionen und wenn
der mindest- und höchstpreis ausreichend
hoch sind geht auch die lenkungswirkung
nicht verloren so ein emissionshandel
mit preiskorridor ist also eine art
verschmelzung aus dem freien
emissionshandel mit der co2 steuer mit
den fixpreisen was durchaus seine
vorteile hat für den preis korridor gibt
es folgende berechnungen im jahr 2020
mindestens 35 euro pro tonne co2 und
maximal 70 euro mit anstieg auf 70 bis
180 euro im jahr 2030 das sind also die
preise die mit unseren klimazielen
kompatibel sind liegt die preise
darunter verfehlt das instrument co2
preis seine wirkung so dann schauen wir
doch mal was sich das klima kabinett der
bundesregierung dazu genau überlegt hat
der plan ist es in den sektoren verkehr
und gebäude jetzt erstmal mit einem co2
fixpreis anzufangen
der mit der zeit ansteigt und dann über
geht in einen emissionshandel mit
preiskorridor natürlich mit dem ziel das
ganze auch auf eu ebene zu etablieren
dieser ganze plan ist
gut nur die preise sind leider ungeil 20
21 soll der fixpreis lächerliche zehn
euro betragen und bis 2025 auf 35 euro
ansteigen fun facts ein co2 preis von 10
euro sorgt an der tankstelle für gerade
mal drei cent mehr pro liter benzin
das liegt weit unter den täglichen
schwankungen 2026 soll dann ein
emissionshandel mit preiskorridor
starten und zwar mit einem mindestpreis
von 35 euro und einem höchstpreis von 60
euro und wii dieser preiskorridor weiter
ansteigen soll wird erst 20 25
beschlossen in der süddeutschen wurde
von christian and sehr verständlich
aufgearbeitet wie weit dieser plan von
der wissenschaftlichen empfehlung
entfernt ist wir werden selbst am ende
dieses klimapakets aus im jahr 20 26 mit
dem co2 preis in keinem wirksamen
bereich liegen sie sieht dass der dann
angedachte maximalpreis er auf minimal
preisniveau liegt gut jetzt kann man
sagen aber was ist mit den ganzen
anderen maßnahmen all die prämien
förderungen investitionen da kann man
sich jetzt natürlich schön tot
diskutieren in all den details sei es
jetzt ob die senkung der mehrwertsteuer
bahntickets überhaupt irgend einer
verhaltensänderung führen wird oder ob
die abwrackprämie bei ölheizungen nicht
viel zu langsam ist aber eigentlich ist
all das nur eine ablenkung von dem
eigentlichen grund problem nämlich das
fehlen eines übergeordneten lenkenden
co2 preises dass sie vorgestellt wird
ist ein flickenteppich aus ordnungsrecht
und förderung ohne wirksamen co2 preis
wovon die experten ganz klar abgeraten
haben unter anderem weil so ein
flickenteppich sich nicht ohne weiteres
auf eu ebene übertragen lässt weil er
nicht effizient ist und doch schwer
sozial gerecht umsetzbar ist nochmal die
experten sagen nicht dass solche
ordnungsrechtlichen maßnahmen an sich
quatsch sind und dass ein co2 preis
alles ist sondern sie sagen
solche maßnahmen müssen einen co2 preis
begleiten wir brauchen erst den preis
und davon ausgehen können wir schauen wo
sind die stellen an denen der preis
alleine nicht reicht und dort setzen wir
prämien förderungen für
nehmen wir mal als beispiel die
pendlerpauschale die für fernpendler
erhöht werden sollen und zwar in einem
ziemlichen missverhältnis zu den minimal
steigenden spritpreisen fun fact wenn
ich mit dem auto 50 kilometer zur arbeit
kenntnis
dann kostet mich dass mit diesem klima
paket im jahr 20 21 weniger als heute
wtf aber selbst wenn man mal von dieser
banane ich kai tab sieht dann schießt
das grundprinzip dieser pendlerpauschale
am ziel vorbei wenn ich pendler bin dann
habe ich ja nur einen anreiz mein auto
stehen zu lassen und auf
klimafreundliche alternativen zu
wechseln wenn der co2 preis hoch genug
ist also wenn autofahren spürbar teurer
wird als klimafreundliche alternativen
klar wenn ich noch nicht mal
alternativen habe zum beispiel im
ländlichen raum
dann muss der ausbau solcher
alternativen also zum beispiel
öffentlicher verkehr an erster stelle
stehen das ist jetzt ein sehr schönes
beispiel dafür wo der co2 preis alleine
nicht reicht und wo man hier ganz
gezielt flankierende zusätzliche
maßnahmen einführen kann eine
pendlerpauschale ist ohne wirksamen co2
preis zwar eine finanzielle entlastung
der pendler hat aber keine
lenkungswirkung also wir kein verhalten
ändern eine sinnvollere und gerechtere
lösung wäre es wenn man erstmal co2
preis hat der entsprechend hoch ist und
die einnahmen aus diesem co2 preis
wieder an die bürger zurück zahlt in
form einer klima dividende oder indem
man die strom steuern senkt das hatten
wir auch schon im letzten video eine
senkung der stromkosten wird im
klimapaket zwar vorgestellt aber es
hielt hier natürlich wieder die
sinnvolle kopplung mit einem ausreichend
hohen co2 preis diese grafik des
mercator instituts bringt die vorteile
auf den punkt ein wirksam hoher co2
preisklima dividende und jedenfalls noch
plus senkt oder stromsteuer stärkt sich
die schwachen und gibt auf dem land und
in der stadt fast gleich also anstatt
einen wust von förderungen und prämien
blind zu setzen empfehlen die experten
erst mal das system co2 preis plus klima
dividende
als hauptinstrument einzusetzen und
davon ausgehend jetzt dann auch zu
schauen wer bleibt jetzt noch als
härtefall zurück unklar
je höher der co2 preis desto mehr geld
haben wir auch für einen sozialen
ausgleich
also nicht zuletzt ist der co2 preis
eine wichtige einnahmequelle und eine
antwort auf die frage wer soll das alles
bezahlen da nun die co2 preise aber viel
zu niedrig sind ist dieses klima paket
nichts anderes als eine aufschiebung des
problems um ein paar jahre und dafür
haben wir keine zeit mehr es ist ja
nicht mehr fünf vor zwölf es ist schon
fünf nach zwölf
unsere ziele für 2020 sind ja quasi
schon verfehlt die bundesregierung hat
sich aber dazu verpflichtet sich von
einem externen experten rat begleiten zu
lassen der auf die einhaltung der
klimaziele schaut und sie hat sich
verpflichtet den kurs anzupassen wenn
wir unsere ziele verfehlen
wie soll ich sagen liebe bundesregierung
liebes klima kabinett es ist jetzt schon
klar dass wir uns auf einem kurs
befinden auf dem wir unsere klimaziele
krachend verfehlen wehren aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht habt ihr also
das go ihr könnt euch jetzt schon wieder
zusammensetzen wenn euch unsere
klimaziele ernsthaft wichtig sind müsst
ihr euch jetzt wieder zusammensetzen und
vielleicht nächstes mal nicht in einer
nachtsitzung nicht immer macht wo es
dann darum geht wer gewinnt den gesäß
oder gehirn wissen sie das ist doch das
doch aberwitzig eine solche komplexe und
komplizierte angelegenheit in der
nachtsitzung zu besprechen sondern
vielleicht mal in einem rahmen der einer
menschheitsaufgabe gericht wird dank
future habt ihr der wissenschaft endlich
gehör geschenkt und euch an eure
klimaziele erinnert für die erreichung
der klimaziele steht euch die
wissenschaftliche expertise weiterhin
zur verfügung und wenn ihr bloß den mut
habt die auch anzuwenden dann dürft ihr
nächstes mal auch ernsthaft verkünden
dass endlich einiges auf den weg
gebracht wurde um den klimawandel
aufzuhalten und all diese leute würden
euch endlich mal feiern wäre das nicht
fantastisch